i thought i would do a few more examples
of taking anti-derivatives just so we
feel comfortable taking anti-derivatives
all of the functions the the basic
functions that we know how to take the
derivatives of and on top of that i just
want to make it clear that it doesn't
always have to be
functions of x here we have a function
of t and we're taking the
anti-derivative with respect to t and so
you would not write a dx here that is
not the notation you'll see why when we
focus on definite integrals so what's
the anti-derivative of this business
right over here well it's going to be
the same thing as the anti-derivative of
sine of t it's going to be the
anti-derivative of sine of t or the
indefinite integral of sine of t plus
the indefinite integral or the
anti-derivative of cosine of t
plus the
antiderivative of cosine of t so let's
think about what these antiderivatives
are and we already know a little bit
about taking the derivatives of trig
functions we know that the derivative
with respect to t of cosine of t
is equal to negative
negative
sine of t
so if we want a sine of t here we just
have to take the derivative of negative
cosine t if we take the derivative of
negative cosine t then we get positive
sine of t derivative with respect to t
of cosine t is negative sine of t we
have the negative out front it becomes
positive sine of t
so the antiderivative of sine of t the
antiderivative is negative cosine of t
so this is going to be equal to
negative cosine of t
and then what's the antiderivative of
cosine of t
well we already know that the derivative
with respect to t of sine of t
is equal to cosine of t so cosine of t
is anti-derivative is just sine of t so
plus
sine
of t and we're done we found
the anti-derivative
now let's tackle this now we don't have
a t where we're we're we're taking the
ant we're taking the indefinite integral
with respect to actually this is a
mistake this should be with respect to a
let me clean this up
this should be a d a if we're taking
this with respect to t that we would
treat all of these things as just
constants but i don't want to confuse
you right now
let me make it clear this is going to be
d a that's what we are integrating or
taking the anti-derivative with respect
to so what is this going to be equal to
well let's once again we can rewrite it
as the sum of integrals this is the
indefinite integral of e to the a
d a so this one right over here
plus
i'll do it in green plus
the
indefinite integral or the
anti-derivative of 1 over a
d a
now
what is the anti-derivative of e to the
a
well we already know a little bit about
exponentials the derivative with respect
to x
of e to the x is equal to e to the x
that's one of the reasons why e in the
exponential function in general is so
amazing and if we just replaced a with
x or x with a you get the derivative
with respect to a of e to the a
is equal to e to the a
so the anti-derivative here the
derivative of e to the a is e to the a
the anti-derivative is going to be e to
the a and maybe you could shift it by
some type of a constant oh and let me
make let me not forget i have to put my
constant right over here i could have a
constant factor so let me
always important remember the constant
so you have a constant factor
right over here
never forget that i almost did so once
again over here what's the
anti-derivative of e to the a
it is
e to the a
what's the anti-derivative of 1 over a
well we've seen that in the last video
it is going to be the natural log of the
absolute value of a and then we want to
have the most general anti-derivative so
there could be a constant factor out
here as well
and we are done we found the
anti-derivative of
both of these both of these expressions